one of the questions we keep asking is
whether the future of the republican
party is in mitt romney
is it in lindsey graham or is it in
marjorie taylor greene
mitt romney being at this point anyway
an anti-trump
republican lindsey graham being a
formerly anti-trump republican who now
is on the trump side and seems to like
golfing with trump and being in the good
graces
of what was then a current and now
former president or
marjorie taylor greene who exists as an
elected official
only because of trump and came to power
by
riding the full-on q anon trumpian wing
of the republican party
and part of it as i've said before
depends on what donald trump's presence
or lack thereof
ends up being meaning what does trump
decide to do based on his letter that we
looked at earlier today
it seems donald trump is planning to at
least try to remain involved in the
republican party and american politics
for the time being but there's another
factor
here which is the electorate the
republican electorate because remember
that
without a wacky republican electorate
trump's candidacy in 2016 goes nowhere
if trump ran in the democratic primary
he would have gotten
nowhere because democratic primary
voters would never have been bamboozled
into making donald trump the nominee so
one of the things that 2016 showed us
was that the electorate matters and that
the electorates are dramatically
different in the republican party
and the democratic party ronald
brownstein wrote
a very interesting op-ed for cnn where
he asks
whether the extremist wing of the
republican party
may be too big to fail and there are
certain numbers that tell us that
yes there are way too many completely
radicalized extreme republicans for them
to be
relegated to political obscurity and
irrelevance maybe even if donald trump
goes quietly
into the night and opts out of american
politics which again for now it doesn't
seem like he's looking to do
and as brownstein points out in this
article uh the american enterprise
institute a right-wing
think tank did a poll and found that
nearly a third
of republicans embrace the convoluted q
anon conspiracy theory
that marjorie taylor greene has been
espousing that trump is defending the
country
against this sort of uh a cabal
of child sex traffickers a third of
republicans believe
that one-sixth to one-fifth of
republicans
have praised the january sixth riots in
polling from quinnipiac
55 percent of republicans agree that
quote we may have to use
force to save the american way of life
four in 10 agree with the phrase if
elected leaders will not protect america
the people must do it themselves even if
it requires taking violent actions
vanderbilt university did a study and
found that 51 percent of republicans
agree with the statement that quote we
may have to use
force to save the traditional american
way of life
four in ten uh back the idea
that a time will come when patriotic
americans have to take the law
into their own hands and in the american
enterprise institute poll
half of republicans said that the attack
on january 6th
was engineered not by trumpists but by
antifa these aren't fringes
when so many people believe this stuff
these aren't five
seven eleven percent beliefs in the
republican party
so yes we should be afraid because if
that contingent takes over the party for
the long term it's a dystopian nightmare
now i think it bears repeating that
trump didn't create
most of this these extremists have been
around in american politics for a long
time
they just didn't always vote they
weren't always
public about their beliefs and they
didn't have a candidate
that coalesced them and brought them out
and that's what's so dangerous about
what's going on right now
so the best scenario is that the party
is split
the romneys have to fight the lindsey
grahams and
the q anon people and they all end up so
busy fighting each other
that they end up unable to stop joe
biden and democrats from hopefully
getting things done now mitch mcconnell
knows that that's the risk part of mitch
mcconnell
voting not guilty on conviction on
saturday and then giving a speech saying
how donald trump is practically speaking
and morally speaking
completely responsible for the riots
part of this is mitch mcconnell
desperate to figure out a way to
not be tied up in fighting so that he
can get back to
what he's an expert in and i say that
not joking he's really an expert in
obstructing democrats from getting
anything done
the best case scenario is that they end
up infighting
and aren't able to obstruct the worst
case scenario is really bad uh
and it includes that they are able to
obstruct and these trumpian clowns the
the q anon types
uh continue getting elected in the
future and
um that gets me really to the next thing
i want to talk about which is that
this is a problem that is much bigger
than one insurrection the insurrection
is a lens
it's a it's a gla it's a not really a
mirror but in a sense it's a mirror
it's a one-way mirror that lets us look
at the bigger problem of
radicalization so i want to talk about
that next